[Music]
I've had the pleasure of interviewing
some of our science fiction writers that
we are connected to and the ones who are
particularly oriented to the science of
science fiction not surprisingly I'm a
big Neal Stephenson fan and if you read
7th Eve's the sections on orbital
mechanics were just poetic as far as I
was concerned I'm an astronaut achill
engineer so it's the kind of stuff I
love I had the chance to interview Andy
we are here about to Mars and the real
interest in modern Mars actually did
begin with Andy weir he's a parvenu he's
recent the real modern interest in Mars
of course we all know began with red
bars blue Mars and green Mars
in fact when my son who is now 26 years
old was just not quite five that was the
first science fiction he and Kevin I
actually read it to him over the course
of a summer all of red Mars through it
and he is now a writer because of it so
Stan actually led to what my son has
become I have a great admiration for it
what we're gonna do tonight is talk
about science we're talking about the
science behind this new book all about
climate change and you're gonna learn
why the robot map here has drawn us New
York City and that dark Tuukka what's
the connection between the two Stan the
floor is yours
well thank you Peter for that kind
introduction and thank you Michael for
this series and everybody for coming and
last year I talked about this book
wealth I was still writing it and and
talked about the kind of what you might
call the financial plot and was invited
to come back to talk about the climate
part of things so my notion here is to
read for a section and then kind of
unpack that same section so that you can
see how the science and section science
fiction kind of works and also learn
more about how my my ass was saved by
James Hansen because I wanted you know I
wanted New York to be looking like that
and so I could have what I called the
super Venice in the book and so this was
driven my notion of sea-level rise was
driven simply by how much sea-level rise
I needed to flood lower Manhattan and
the topographical map showed me that it
was about 50 feet and that's a lot
that's an awful lot so I will read you a
bit and then describe to you how James
Hansen came to my rescue the first pulse
was not ignored by an entire generation
of ounce brains that is a myth although
like most myths it has some truth to it
which has since been exaggerated the
truth is that the first pulse was a
profound shock how could it not be
raising sea level by 10 feet in 10 years
that was already enough to disrupt
coastlines everywhere also to grossly
inconvenience all the major shipping
ports around the world and shipping his
trade those containers in their millions
have been circulating by way of diesel
burning ships and trucks moving around
all the stuff people wanted produce on
one continent and consumed on another
following the highest rate of return
which is the only rule that people
observed at that time so that very
disregard for the consequences of their
carbon burn had unleashed the ice that
caused the rise of sea level that
wrecked the global distribution system
and caused the depression that was even
more damaging to the
of that generation then accompanying
refugee crisis which using the unit
popular at the time was rated at 50
Katrina's pretty bad but the bridge
frowned interruption of world trade was
even worse as far as business was
concerned so yes
the first pulse was a first-order
catastrophe and it got people's
attention and changes were made sure
people stopped burning carbon much
faster than they thought they could
before the first pulse they closed that
barn door the very second though horses
had gotten out the four horses to be
exact too late of course the global
warming initiated before the first pulse
was baked in by then and could not be
stopped by anything that the post pulse
people could do so despite changing
everything and decarbonizing as fast as
they should have fifty years earlier
they were still cooked like bugs on a
griddle even toss in a few billion tons
of sulfur dioxide into the atmosphere to
mimic a volcanic eruption and thus
deflect a fair bit of sunlight
depressing temperatures for a decade or
two which they did in the twenty-sixth
East a great fanfare and/or gnashing of
teeth was not enough to halt the warming
because the relevant heat was already
deep in the oceans and it wasn't going
anywhere anytime soon no matter how
people played with the global thermostat
imagining that they had godlike powers
they didn't so it was that ocean heat
that caused the first post opposed and
later brought on the second one people
sometimes say no one saw it coming but
no wrong they did paleoclimatologists
looked at the modern situation and saw
co2 levels screaming up from 280 to 450
parts per million in less than 300 years
faster than it ever happened in the
Earth's entire previous five billion
years can we say Anthropocene Klaus and
they searched the glory illogical record
for the best analogs to this
unprecedented event and they said whoa
they said holy [ __ ] people they said
sea-level rise during the Eemian period
they said which we've been looking at
the world saw temperature rise only half
as big as the one we've just created and
rapid dramatic sea level rise followed
immediately they put it in
bumper-sticker terms massive sea level
rise sure to follow our unprecedented
release of co2 they published their
papers and shouted and waved their arms
and a few canny and deeply thoughtful
sci-fi writers wrote up lurid accounts
of
to allottee and the rest of civilization
went on torching the planet like a
Burning Man pyro masterpiece really
that's how much those knuckleheads cared
about their grandchildren and that's how
much they believed their scientists even
though every time they felt a slight
cold coming on they ran to the nearest
scientists ie
doctor to see Kate so the people of the
2060 staggered on through the great
depression that followed the first pulse
and of course there was a crowd in that
generation a certain particular 1% of
the population that just by chance wrote
things out rather well and considered
that it was really an act of creative
destruction as was everything bad that
didn't touch them and all people needed
to do to deal with it was to buckle down
in their traces and accept the idea of
austerity meaning more poverty for the
poor and accept the police state with
lots of free speech and freaky
lifestyles velvet globe in the iron fist
and hey presto on we go with the show
humans are so tough but pause ever so
slightly and those of you anxious to get
back to the narrator into the antics of
individual humans can skip to the next
chapter and know that any more
expository rants any more info dumps on
your carpet from this New Yorker will be
printed in red ink to warn you to skip
them paws broader minded more
intellectually flexible readers to
consider why the first pulse happened in
the first place
any Antarctic ice that slides into the
ocean floats away leaving more four more
to slide and in the 21st century as
during the three million years before
that a lot of Antarctic ice was piled up
on Basin slopes meaning giant valleys
which angled down into the ocean ice
slides downhill just like water only
slower although if sliding skimboarding
on a layer of liquid water not that much
slower so all the ice hanging over the
edge of the ocean was perched there and
not sliding very fast because there were
buttresses of ice right at the waterline
or just below it then were basically
stuck in place this ice at the shoreline
laid directly on the ground stuck there
by its own massive weight thus forming
in effect long drams wringing all of
Antarctica dams that somewhat held in
place the big basins of ice uphill from
them but these ice buttresses that the
ocean ends of these very huge ice basins
were mainly held in place by their
leading
badges which are grounded underwater
slightly offshore still held to the
ground by their own massive weight but
caught under water on rock shelves
offshore that rose up like the low edges
of a bowl the result of earlier iced
action in previous epochs these
outermost edges of the ice dams were
called by scientists the buttress of the
buttress don't you love that phrase
so yeah the buttresses of the buttresses
were there in place but as the phrase
might suggest to you they were not huge
in comparison to the masses of ice they
were holding back nor will they will
emplaced
they were just lying there in the
shallows of Antarctica that comment
sized cake of ice that cake of ice
10,000 feet thick and 15 Hyundai ammeter
do the math on that Oh numerate ones
among you and for the rest 230 foot
sea-level rise is the answer given
earlier and lastly those rapidly warming
circumpolar ocean currents already
mentioned were circulating mainly about
a kilometre to down meaning you guessed
it right at the level where the
buttresses of the buttresses were
resting and ice though it sits on land
and even on land bottoming shallow water
weren't heavy enough floats on water
when water gets under as is well known
consult your cocktail for confirmation
of this phenomena so the first pulse was
mostly the Wilkes Victoria Basin also
Greenland also West Antarctica another
less massive but consequential
contributor as its basins lay almost
entirely below sea levels such as they
were quick to break there but roses and
then float up on the sub Trudie notion
water and sail away all this ice
breaking up and sailing into the Seas
years of greatest rise 20:52 to 2061 and
suddenly the ocean was ten feet higher
oh no how could it be rates have changed
themself change
that's how say the speed of melting
doubles every 10 years how many decades
before you are [ __ ]
not many it resembles compound interest
or recall the old story of the great
Mughal emperor who was talked into
repaying a peasant who had saved his
life by giving the peasant one grain of
rice and then two and doubling that
again on every square of a chessboard
possibly the Grand Vizier our chief
astronomer advised this payment or the
canny peasant and the unquote
improver said sure good deal rice drains
who cares and started to dribble out the
payment having been well trained in
counting rice grains by a certain
passing Serbian dervish woman couple few
rows into the chessboard he sees how
he's been had and has the Vizier or
astronomer or peasant beheaded maybe all
three that would be Imperial style the
1% get nasty when their assets are
threatened so that's how it happened
with the first pulse big surprise what
about the second pulse you asked don't
ask it was just more of the same double
does everything loosened in the
increasing warmth in the higher seas
mainly the Aurora basins buttress let
loose and it's ice float down the Totten
glacier the aurora was a basin even
bigger than the Wilkes Victoria and then
with sea level raised 15 feet then 20
feet all of the buttresses of the budget
has lost their footing all the way
around Antarctica continent after which
said buttresses were shot from behind
into the sea after which gravity had its
wave at the ice and all the basins all
around East Antarctica and the ice
resting on ground below sea level in
West Antarctica and all that ice quickly
melted when it hit water and even when
it was still ice and floating often in
the form of tabular Berg's the size of
major nations it was already displaced
in the ocean by as much as it would when
it finished melting why that should be
as left as an exercise for the reader to
solve after which you can run naked from
your leaky bath crane Eureka
but hey an end is a beginning creative
destruction right apply more police
state and more austerity clamp down hard
proceed as before cleaning up the mess a
great investment opportunity turn baby
turn and the citizen who is the voice
that you're hearing there goes on at
some length but I'll stop at that point
and thank you
I just read a review of this yesterday
that said by my good friend John clued
the encyclopedias of science fiction who
said that the citizen is obviously KSR
unbound at last that the radioactive
heart of info dumps I believe he called
him so I'm proud of that and so ok I
wanted 50-foot sea level rise by 21 40
whatever I needed it as soon as possible
because I wanted to talk about the
financial crash of 2008 and how we could
do better next time so on the one hand I
wanted to be as soon as possible in the
future as possible on the other hand I
wanted 50-foot sea level rise
the IPCC at this point is saying that by
the end of this century seeable of lives
will max out at like 1 meter so I had a
discrepancy there and lo and behold
James Hansen at all 18 co-authors 2016
paper while I was actually in the midst
of writing this book but obviously not
the passage I just read to you which
comes after the paper involved because
what the this rant does is pretty much
give you the results of this Hansen
paper what Hansen and his colleagues
wanted to say to the world is the IPCC
in attempting to be conservative in
attempting to say only something that
they can back up needed to give a quite
small figure for the potential sea level
rise in the next hundred years and of
course history isn't going to stop in
hundred years but in any case it's a
conservative estimate and indeed you
know as far as we can tell in the last
hundred years you can measure sea-level
rise in millimeters so it isn't as if
anything has happened yet I believe I
just this afternoon reading in Discover
Magazine so that between 1850 and now
sea level has risen about a foot so when
you're talking about 50 feet you needed
something and here's Hansen the economic
and social cost of losing functionality
of all coastal cities is practically
uncalculated adaptation will not work so
what he says in this paper with his 19
colleagues is actually a very strange
case it's cobbled together like a house
of cards and indeed if you pull out any
card
the total house
falls to the ground and so it's rickety
and it has been criticized and Hansen of
course now as a political figure
he's not just a scientist the NASA
scientists did all this great work he's
also the guy that laid down in front of
the tranqs in order to get arrested in
order to protest coal coal trains I
believe was what he laid down in front
of so when he writes a paper and says
look we've completely underestimated the
rapidity of sea-level rise the suspicion
of this paper was extreme and the paper
is rickety I would be very interested to
hear an analysis by a real scientist cuz
along the way Hansen will say well if
thing if the doubling rate of sea level
rise goes every 10 years you've got a
certain rate if it's 20 years you've got
another rate if you if you've got every
40 years you've got another rate well
anybody can say that and it's true but
there's no evidence as to which rate
we're on because we're at the part of
the graph where things are just moving
horizontally and how the jump will
happen isn't is unknown to us right now
so he's doing an act of science fiction
in nonfiction form and that can be
challenged as such the effect of many
work of science fiction in nonfiction
form it's a genre so he had to go back
to the Eemian as my narrator says the
Eemian is about 130 to 120 thousand
years ago it's the last big interglacial
during that time he says temperatures
only went up about one degree Celsius in
other words what we've already done now
we've already done this since the
Industrial Revolution and sea level
seems to have gone up within a century
about 10 meters and maybe more and so
for me with my need and for my story's
purposes I read this paper going wow
this is like a gift from God
I've got justification for what I'm
doing here and this is a little perverse
and there are other people a little more
concerned about rapid massive sea-level
rise than I was when I was reading this
paper and loving it for how it was
helping me in my book but the thing is a
hundred and twenty five thousand years
ago
finding where sea level was is a really
tough problem in paleo geology because
of luth aesthetic rebound ice weighs
down the lithosphere then the ice goes
away
the loofah sphere rebounds there was a
sea level rise there but was that our
was that land there when the sea level
rise was there or not so these things
have to be correlated and the evidence
that Hanson and his team had for where
sea level was and how fast it rose were
both about as tenuous as scientific
evidence gets a lot of it comes from the
Bahamas and Bermuda and there are two
different ways that they're estimating
sea level at the time of a hundred and
twenty-five thousand years ago coral
reefs how high can they be but of course
coral reefs can be two feet underwater
or right at the tide line or they can be
15 feet underwater so that's another bit
of guesswork and then the kind of
carbonate the platform that is the
Bahamas is quickly established by
microorganisms that die go down their
cement really fast and turn into blocks
that then had to have been very very
near sea level at the time that they
were formed and so these are the two
best ways of estimating where sea level
was and you still have to take into
account lithostatic rebound or not so
then there are also findings in Bermuda
the Mediterranean Papua New Guinea
South Carolina and West Australia and so
these places are also evidence and
brought into place for what was sea
level back then and how fast did it rise
and then the handsome complicates this
case in this very same paper by saying
not only do we see that the a mian had
very rapid sea level rise with only a
small temperature rise but also there
were super storms as a result and this
has to do with a larger case he's making
that the driver of world climate is the
Southern Ocean going around Antarctica
what it does drives everything else they
claim and it used to be the Atlantic or
the gigantic ocean current that goes
from the Pacific into the Indian into
the Atlantic all the way up the Atlantic
sinks to the bottom between Greenland
and Norway and goes down the other
direction any single water molecule
takes about a thousand years to make
this circuit and that was said to be the
great world climate driver in terms of
Earth's assists
but now Hanson and his team is claiming
that it's a Southern Ocean going around
Antarctica and also saying that when
things change like they're changing now
a slight rise in temperature you get
super storms in the Atlantic and their
evidence is these gigantic boulders a
thousand ton boulders that are 40 feet
above sea level in Bermuda and it seems
like there's nothing that could have put
them there except for really big waves
and I'm thinking thousand tons forty
feet higher that's really big waves but
there's no other mechanism to get them
there at least Hansen and his team of
colleagues claimed that so this is a
little well how are you going to say
that a hundred twenty-five thousand
years ago there were hurricanes that
were five times the size of current
hurricanes
you know that what weathermen around
climatologists are wrong and here we
have a claim about the strength of
storms except for evidence like this
these these boulders sitting up high on
Bermuda
there isn't a real strong case to be
made there so you have a pretty funky
case that Hansen and his team has made
and what I think he's doing is yet again
waving the the red flag of danger and
trying and he's not worried about the
weakness of the case scientifically he's
not worried about I mean this was a
peer-reviewed paper but God knows what
the peer reviewers said I'm I I live
with a chemist and I'm just amazed at
some of the stuff that appear that
chemists will say that peer of your
viewers will say and I will say this
this paper is controversial for a reason
but the UN Framework Convention on
Climate Change has agreed that we need
to limit global warming to two degrees
Celsius and Hansen a saint that does not
provide us with safety that's not good
enough he's saying there is a real
danger that we will hand young people in
future generations a climate system that
is practically out of their control
he said we have a global emergency and
fossil fuel co2 emissions should be
reduced as rapidly as practical well
this is like back to science speak as
rapidly as practical I mean this is
suddenly this concern
last sentence he didn't dare to say we
need to reduce it now we need to reduce
it as rapidly as possible it's as
rapidly as practical is this because he
took a step back at the edge of the
cliff before throwing himself into the
world of politics now briefly I want to
talk about another paper that came up
about the same time this sea level rise
it seems like it's gonna happen to one
degree or another and I would say as an
English major who reads scientific
papers with great interest but no
expertise whatsoever except as a citizen
scientist you know who's been reading
science news for 35 years that we just
don't know right now how much sea level
rise how fast
who the hell knows you can you can make
a scenario and scenario building is
something that Peter doesn't can talk
about you cannot say for sure but what
if we do get sea level rise and it seems
like we're going to get it to some
degree another could we do this cool
thing which is mentioned and described
in detail in my book green earth as a
stupid geoengineering idea because I
wrote it 10 years ago and I was I
thought it was a joke but the Potsdam
Institute a very serious scientific
think-tank in Germany has actually asked
done a study of this very same idea
could we pump seawater back up to the
top of the Antarctic Plateau it freezes
there it's very very cold there and then
lo and behold sea level rise is solved
you just the ice that's flowing into the
sea that's causing sea level rise you
pump it back up to the top and then you
know what if you have to do it forever
so what we're already managing this
planet we are already accidental and
managing isn't the right word because
managing would imply believe we know
what we're doing and we're good at it
we're we're finessing we're begging were
we're begging this planet to cooperate
with us so that we can stay alive on it
and we're finessing it we're trying
things out especially ideas so the pasta
min suit says the headline is this for
the further abstract sea level rise too
big to be pumped away I'm thinking how
do they know let's let's examine this a
little more carefully the weight of ice
pumped on to the ice cap would speed the
push of ice into the sea at the coast
and I've been to an arch and I'm saying
no way that's not a problem you pump it
to the middle of Antarctica and it's
gonna be a long time before it pushes
the coast
believe me it's it's as big as the
United States and and Mexico combined
it's and it's ten thousand feet thick of
ice and the coasts are out there if you
pump it up to about the middle of the
word Antarctica
well the Postum Institute says it would
stay for about a thousand years I'm
thinking thousand years is good enough
they'll figure out something or we'll
just do it forever so then they how much
power how much electricity to pump that
up when I wrote green Mars I thought we
just make a bunch of wind turbines you
magic with a bunch of solar collectors
it has to be clean power if you burn
carbon to do this
you're just doubling your problem it's
like oh my god digging a hole to bury
yourself so with clean power how much
power would you need they estimate it
would require one tenth of the present
annual global energy supply well I was I
guess I would have guessed a hundred one
hundredths of that or one tenth but I'm
just guessing and I'm an English major
it was just a five you know water you
pump it uphill how bad could it be but
it's a lot of water and it's 10,000
vertical feet and so I trust their
figures they're German scientists I'm
sure they got that right
so then how many wind turbines is that
given current wind turbines that's why
they put it this way it's again so phi
850,000 wind turbines whoa it's a lot of
wind turbines why not just call it a
million wind turbines you know rounding
error I mean just make it simple you
need a million wind turbines to power
the moving of sea level you know of
seawater back up to the in Arctic cap
well I think they may be talking about
doing that it would be cheaper than
what's gonna happen if there is the 10
to 50 feet of sea-level rise because the
coastal area is the world our shipping
and trade as my citizens said it's also
a lot of agriculture aquaculture it's
about 1/10 of the world's population it
and in terms of the monetary value of
the infrastructure the built
infrastructure I calculate a ghazal
in beryllium dollars this is and my
insurance guy at Swiss read I asked him
you know could you am I right about that
and he's going yes the swiss friend he
goes don't even try to calculate that
one that one is indeed is like why not
just call it infinity so a million wind
turbines what if they were made of
plastic what if you had a 3d printer
what if you had robots printing them
what if you had what if you didn't
wanted to do it bad enough what if it
became part of saving civilization well
we might end up doing it the potential
if all of Antarctica melts as I guess
the citizen pointed out is about two
hundred and thirty feet of sea-level
rise that would mean that we would be
like two hundred feet underwater here or
maybe two hundred twenty feet underwater
right here and there are some good maps
of San Francisco with the full two
hundred and thirty feet rise they're
crazy because that that is not likely to
happen because the cake in Antarctica
with the beam at the poles being very
very cold in the winter we can be
confident it won't be the two hundred
and thirty feet but it might be a lot
and before I finish and am on time the
the the reason these estimates have
changed is this Totten glacier and the
Wilke glacier these are really big
basins that are that if the ice in them
is allowed to slide out one of them is 3
to 4 meters of sea level rise all by
itself the other one is five to six
meters of sea level rise all by itself
and Greenland is is a four to six meters
of sea level rise all by itself
Greenland's different from Antarctica
because it's in a bathtub of a rock with
only a few breaks in the bathtub of Rock
that's why I talked about the leaky
bathtub that Archimedes leaps out of
you've got this issue where Antarctica
has deep valleys that are as big as the
Grand Canyon and two or three kilometers
below sea level ready to get warm and
slide all that ice off into the sea so
probably the IPCC is wrong
probably Hansen to one degree or another
is
right a warning flag got put up in the
middle of 2016 and as gavin newsom said
when they informed him at a recent
meeting that california might see a
seven-foot sea level rise in seven at
ten foot like in the next century and
then sea level rises worse in California
than the rest of the world because we're
such a special state in so many ways he
said well what am I supposed to do with
that what are we supposed to do with
that well it's a good question what are
we supposed to do with that big problems
I lastly we just want to thank auto the
automatic drawer for this incredible map
of New York and maybe there's one more
point since I do have three minutes left
I went to a meeting in a Trinity Church
on Wall Street right next to where
George Washington was made president and
we were one of the Trump Towers is it's
a very weird place and there we talked
about sea level rise and I read the
chapter about how the beavers were going
to take over Manhattan and the next
panel to get up to speak one guy was
very irate I don't want to give him an
Hatton back to the beavers which I
thought was you know a motto it should
be a t-shirt I personally think
Manhattan would be way better off with
the Beavers and that's kind of what my
novel is about you know the coming back
of the animals but what they were about
in that panel was storm surge protection
from Manhattan they rejected my thesis
entirely which has happened in a lot
when I was in New York I noticed and
between Sandy Hook and the Rockaway
breezy point on Long Island they
proposed the shallow they proposed to
build a barrier there with an in and out
for ships and and they can close it off
during storm surges I got up afterwards
and I said well what about Long Island
son you're gonna put another barrier at
Hell Gate he goes no we're gonna put it
at frogs neck so I guess that's a little
further out there and then I said but
wait a second the Hudson is like three
hundred thousand cubic feet per second
even normally it's not a lagoon like
Venice because they're thinking Venice
because the Lido is now blocked off in
Venice and the Adriatic can be up to 20
to 30 feet higher than lagoon and Venice
will not get drowned anymore and that's
what these people in New York are
thinking but meanwhile the Hudson is
pouring down in
and is here so I said this is not a this
is not a proper solution to the problem
of sea-level rise no he said it's a
storm surge barrier I'm thinking okay
but you're you're gonna spend billions
for a storm surge barrier while sea
level is rising to the point where you
would never be able to open the gates
and then the Hudson would flood you so
current plans and with that I'm on time
and can quit current plans for what to
do for New York no way you'd be better
off trying to put the sea water back on
top of Antarctica which is also of
course crazy and so it's worth talking
when Peter gets up or maybe we'll talk
about geoengineering about what we can
do the obvious thing is decarbonisation
as fast as possible that's but that's
always been the obvious thing and now
since we're not doing that very well we
we begin to talk about geoengineering in
the most serious way so that's what
we've really been talking about here
well now Peter come on up and we'll go
on from there great
that was great Stan so what I suggest
what we're gonna do is we're gonna talk
a little bit and then we'll throw it
open for comments questions discussion
from the rest of you I want to be get a
little bit with the climate change
discussion I want to talk a little bit
about geoengineering about the book
itself sure what the hell of a good book
right I mean you know yes great science
and all that but it's also a good book I
don't cuz the book is different from
some of the other books and I want to
talk a little bit about that but let's
talk about the science because you you
raised some of the questions about Jim
Hansen's paper and I'm a Jim Hansen fan
like you and my first effort to deal
with climate change actually goes back
to 1977 when I was at Stanford Research
Institute and we did one of the first
global climate assessments and my
background is actually fluid mechanics
I'm actually a rocket scientist by
education the only virtue of my degrees
I actually get to say that that I am a
rocket scientist but I did the fluid
mechanics of the model and the
conclusion we came to was that the world
was looking at a period of fairly
dynamic climate not just a gradually
warming climate but rapid swings around
an average that might be rising in terms
of temperature in 2004 Stewart Brand and
I wrote a paper for the Pentagon or
abrupt climate change that was built on
the idea of a recurrence of an event
which occurred eight thousand two
hundred years ago in which the climate
of the northern hemisphere cooled rather
dramatically for ten years
stayed cold and dry for a century and
then came back up again we did that
because we didn't want to try and model
the future we said look this actually
happened it could happen again and so I
was looking at what the implications of
that were and I think more and more the
evidence suggests that I think the model
you presented whether it is the
particulars of the the berms that
Antarctica the particular flows almost
doesn't matter that there are a number
of different mechanisms by which abrupt
change can happen where very rapid
change can happen the one you've
described is one plausible one other
ones are the drop at the end of the
Atlantic conveyor that would been ups to
the Gulf Stream that would result from
lots of fresh water coming off of the
glacier
of Greenland that might lead to changes
in the salinity so there's a number of
different mechanisms by which the world
could change rather dramatically and I
think I think one of the great virtues
of the book is it doesn't present the
conventional view of a kind of gradually
warming world but abrupt shifts that are
extremely difficult challenging you made
a choice to put it that way why well two
things and one of them is just that it
is very hard to dramatize and write
novels about something that will creep
up on us over a period of a couple
hundred years
that's simply a hard story to tell so
you want you look for the abrupt events
and this has been a problem facing me
ever since I first talked to climate
scientists about it where I asked how
fast West Antarctic Ice Sheet come could
come off and Donald blankenship
University goes really fast and I said
how fast and he goes five hundred years
he's a geologist so then you needed I
needed to find things faster than that
well it was Richard alley and I was 2002
abrupt climate change is not even a term
until 2002 the group called abrupt
climate change yeah and I report for the
National Research Council the Greenland
ice core data showed this eight thousand
two hundred year event ago event or even
the Younger Dryas itself where you go in
three years you go from a world climate
that is warm and wet to cool and dry in
a three year period and the ice data are
quite convincing on that so then you
look and you go well we should that's
abrupt and they didn't have a word for
it because these are people who thought
five hundred years was abrupt before so
that's why this term abrupt climate
change in a new report and essentially
they had been Peter crying wolf you know
things are gonna happen fast it'll be
within two thousand years and then they
suddenly find things happening in three
years and that's what I wrote up in the
book that's over there called Green
Earth so ok it's obvious that you need
dramatic reasons you want the faster the
crisis the easier it is to dramatize in
a novel but then also it's the
responding to reality itself these are
the news stories coming in if we manage
to release methane that it's caught in
the permafrost in the Arctic
if the Narvik if the Arctic Ocean
doesn't have any ice whatsoever and the
Sun Goes Down in there and heats that
arctic ocean really really fast you know
and we lose our beYOU know I mean there
were there are some tipping points as
they called them and that's not a bad
way to think of it and those are the
ones that the writer seizes and you know
in fact Stuart and I also involved in
another study on abrupt change about the
ice-free Arctic and one of the things
you find there in terms of the politics
of it which are particularly vexed of
course there's one country that actually
gains from climate change well yeah all
the Arctic countries well particularly
Russia Russia is a big it's a blot
they've hacked us yes the Russians yet
they you know they like climate change
why think Siberia nice warm climate as a
result think the northern passage
suddenly you've got an opportunity they
think of that as the Great Sea Road they
call it so you know from their point of
view climate change is a good thing they
have one of the worst climates on the
planet they'd like to see climate change
yeah but they're not gonna like it when
the permafrost melts because that's a
taiga that's the I mean a whole lot of
Russia is in such a position that when
that turns into a swamp all the time and
they use their frozen rivers for roads
and I don't have those frozen rivers
they don't have roads Russia will have
as about as much trouble as anyone else
and Russian scientists will tell the
government that so I don't think I you
know what they sign they're creating so
much less carbon than we are at partly
because their economy crashed but yeah
each one of these tipping points has a
different scenario that are multiple
scenarios and that's one of the one of
the problems is that it's a Garden of
forking paths that at every fork in the
path you have five or six different
stories that could eventually from that
particular and then it goes on and it
goes on and this is why you get science
fiction well but I look I think this is
very useful science fiction in that
respect the science of the science
fiction is very important I had the
privilege of representing Salesforce in
the climate talks last year in Paris and
I think I wish I'd had this book around
then because of course they were all
talking about gradual climate change
and and I actually think that the abrupt
change is a much more probable scenario
that the models don't actually really
work for gradual change that the
unevenness of the earth in all its
different ways will generate fairly
abrupt change and so I think your model
is actually a much more perceptive one
the thing that was very difficult to put
on the agenda in Paris was
geoengineering right nobody wanted to
talk about geoengineering because
everybody was afraid that would take the
adaptation and mitigation off the map
right so right now you've just raised
the issue of geoengineering we just had
a major report come out on
geoengineering literally just a few
weeks ago is there a scenario in your
mind by which we could actually get to
that kind you know you think about the
politics of any country or any group of
countries in a serious way trying to
modify the atmosphere change the albedo
do things like putting iron filings in
the ocean all the different kinds of
ways in which we've talked about it is
there a scenario for actually getting
from here to there not a good one it
wouldn't make a great novel to try to
tell it because no one will like this
plan even the scientists that are
studying the various geoengineering
proposals that are being made and
there's you know half a dozen to a dozen
of them working on this right now they
don't like it and they and they're under
attack constantly for it by various
kinds of environmentalists I think it's
hubris and it also creates a moral
hazard if we think we can geo engineer
our way out of it then maybe we don't
have to stop burning carbon as fast as
we'd otherwise as a moral hazard this is
a problem but what these scientists are
saying is if we get into a situation
where we really want some mitigation
fast like a sudden giant plume of
methane where we look like we're gonna
get a 10 degree centigrade raise in 20
years we might do anything for a while
including this main one the main
proposal is I'm sure you know this the
volcanic eruption imitation pump a bunch
of sulfur dioxide into the upper
atmosphere it falls back down to the
ground so after about five years your
your experiment is over and you can't
permanently thresh the world and create
snowpiercer we're not that powerful so
you can try
Spearman's with without maybe wrecking
things but you have that moral hazard of
oh wait a second in our back pocket we
have magical cures and none of them are
good enough none of them are great
silver bullets if you were to do the
sulfur dioxide if you were to increase
the albedo and bounce some light away
two percent less albedo and do like
Pinto Nouveau did you still have ocean
acidification happening from our carbon
burn most well half of the co2 or a
third to a half of the co2 we put in the
atmosphere ends up in the ocean the
ocean is measurably different than it
wasn't we stirred first started
measuring it on a pH scale as it gets
more acidic the stuff at the bottom of
the food chain in the ocean might get
killed we don't know but it's there made
of calcium carbonate a lot of them in
terms of their meaning shells so it
sounds bad to have a more acidic
environment for them well are you really
gonna try that and then it's going to be
a vexed topic I actually think this
pumping of seawater to the top of
Antarctica is one of the least dangerous
sounding ideas of all and it's peculiar
because that doesn't solve increasing
temperatures droughts extinctions all
the other stuff there and also
geoengineering is probably the wrong
word because engineering again implies
that we know what we're doing so it
should be geo finessing or geo a
gambling geo beggin beggin gaya yeah
you know if we kiss your toe will you
not kick us this is how it should be
regarded and so calling it
geoengineering is already one political
strike against us
it sounds like like a term like say
population control well this is a term
you should never use in the world people
immediately think wait what kind of
fascist horrific stuff is this because
of the name and geoengineering has a
immediate bad ring to it but even if we
get serious about it we've got terrible
trouble so I want to talk not just about
this book but your books because I like
like many others I've read many of your
books not them all but many and and
Stewart and I were involved with another
organization 30 years ago called the
Santa Fe Institute which was about
studying complexity
complexity seems to be an underlying
theme through most of your or many I
won't say most but all the ones I've a
for example the recent one prior to this
is a book called Aurora about a starship
and things don't go so well because
systems don't ultimately function
particularly well the paolo political
systems begin to break down the social
system the economic systems all these
things that depend upon complex organic
functions self-organizing for the
bottom-up as opposed to human beings
figuring them out and making them work
you seem to have a deep suspicion of our
ability to understand and manage
complexity oh well we we we do pretty
well in some ways and then it's too
complex to do really well I you know I
I'm an English major and I write novels
and the reason I write science fiction
novels is because I think those make the
best novels today because we're in a
science fiction novel and so it's the
best realism and so right on that was
good better deeper yeah all in a science
fiction well we are and we're
co-authoring it together and it's it's
so it's a Wow in fact it's getting
weirder and weirder yes every year which
is kind of beautiful and kind of
terrifying
Hunter Thompson did have it right didn't
he yeah maybe but I I guess what I'm
saying is that I when you try to write a
novel
the cool thing about science fiction is
not only is it the best realism of our
time but it also goes beyond the
domestic realist novel of the mid 20th
century a kind of imitation high
modernism would say that it's always
about individuals all about characters
and it has to be stuff that people would
really do like on a college campus or on
an adventure somewhere this version of
the novel was individual and an
individual story of a divorced story of
a person with Tourette's syndrome
on and on it goes well the
nineteenth-century novel was about
individual and individual and individual
and society history and that's why the
big 19th century novel still appeal to
us and that's what this imitation
modernism law
and so science fiction not only gets us
back to individual individual
individuals society individual in
history but also individual and planet
and this is something that's maybe a
little bit new to literature that that
the novel would also include the
relationship between people history and
planet civilisation planet and
civilization as an ecological balancing
act so this is good this is makes for
new novels it makes for big novels and
long vowels and so complexity comes into
it just as part of the novel becoming
back going back to its 19th century
sense of scale and and so I love that
part of what science fiction gives me
and you've given something else with
this novel this is where I'll wrap up
don't throw it open for question
I each of your books has some elements
of style that vary and so on and one of
the things I loved about this one was
that at the beginning of each chapter
you have you this is a very literate
book I have to sell tell you you're
gonna be checking your Wikipedia fairly
often for authors ideas etc it's a
wonderfully literate book and before
each chapter you have quotes mostly and
a few would amount to poems that you
wrote as part of it but just to read two
quick quotes one that I particularly
loved later in the book in a storm the
Flatiron appeared to be moving toward me
like the bow of a monster ocean steamer
a picture of new America still in the
making said Alfred Stieglitz
about the Flatiron Building in New York
you can just love that image just before
the thing you read to us about the
mechanism you go on a long wonderful rap
that you could be straight out of Allen
Ginsberg drowned hosed visiting Davy
Jones six fathoms under wet all wet
moldy mildew title Marcy splashing
surfin body surfing diving drinking in
the drink drunk dance scuba is plunged
high diving sloshed drunk down and goes
on but wonderfully poetic moments here
you went in a different way
stylistically you have eight different
voices in here different
characters including the citizen which
you read from talked a little bit about
how you approached this book and it's
very different from your others well
it's a it it was a beautiful thing I
wanted to write about global finance as
I talked about last year and I told my
editor that and he said that's a
terrible idea Stan and I said well but I
want to and then he said well could you
put it in that drown New York that you
visited for ten pages in in 2312 an
earlier novel of mine I thought well
that's a good idea and then he said you
know if you're gonna put it in New York
you need a whole range of characters
once you do like those French apartment
novels where all the characters live in
the same building they don't necessarily
know each other at the beginning but
later I'm going to shut up Tim I mean
that's enough right oh I'll take it from
here but it was a is a great idea and
and so I did a building novel and I
picked the old Metropolitan Life Tower
which is the original one right next to
the Flatiron and it's built as an
imitation of the Campanile a and in
Venice so I have a Venetian building
already although it's maybe 10 times
taller and so I chose that building I
put my characters in it and then it'd be
in a New York story at a certain point
the stories about New York the little
epigraphs you know remember George Eliot
and Middlemarch every chapter has an
epigraph and that that's a it's like too
many so I decided to double down and I
have four or five epigraphs for every
chapter I just I throw in every single
New York story that truck struck me as
worth telling so that there that's one
of the reasons why it's so so fat the
couple that I liked the most and some of
them are my own lines the invisible hand
never picks up the check this is a the
only light of mine that's on the
Internet as a kind of meme that doesn't
come from me and there's a market for
markets that's Donald Mackenzie of the
Financial Times there's a story about
Thomas Alva Edison filming the
electrocution of an elephant on Coney
Island as an entertainment event 1,500
people gathered to see an elephant get
electrocuted something like you know
Edison was
big on lots of volts or watts anyway it
was something like 6600 volts
put through this elephant so they kind
of cooked it and it was a you know an
entertainment of it and then next year
three elephants disappeared from the
Coney Island zoo whoa they're gone and
then one of them they found over on
Staten Island you thinking elephant swam
across New York Bay about three miles in
order and and the and then the other two
were never found again and I was
imagining them like yetis you know
they're they're living in Long Island
nobody ever sees them again but then my
wife is started in as an behavior since
she explained to me that elephants tend
to hang together so probably they all
headed for Staten Island and two of them
drown on the trip so these are the kind
of bizarre and yet they really happen
type New York stories that you can't do
without if you're gonna do in New York
novel so yeah I had fun with it and
after Aurora I needed fun so yeah roars
pretty grim very good rest now but
they're quite wonderful and wonderfully
literate and and and I have to say you
know I'm a speed reader I used to teach
speed reading I couldn't speed read this
it was City granite
I've tried and it just kept grabbing me
both the writing the ideas and so on so
I just had to read every word and it was
delicious all right now let's open it up
for questions arguments from the floor
Michael will hand you the mic that's
right
Leo's got a mic and I've got a mic and
just a quick shout out to the folks that
are listening we've got a bunch of lone
now members listening online you guys
can send in your questions as well but
who's got a question just raise your
hand and we'll get a mic to you there we
go
start off this could be an entirely bad
idea but I thinking that if I wanted to
carry water up a hill say I'm out in
Antarctica I'd probably rather carry
balloons full of steam than buckets full
of water
interesting idea we got one more plan
all right
the balloons full of steam right yeah I
I'm wondering about the physics of that
steam probably weighs the same as the
water that it constituted but whatever
do we need better ideas than the ones
that we've got I was thinking everybody
could carry one backpack of water
yeah the adventure travel needs some
point right over here oh yeah hey thank
you so much I was curious if you looked
at in kind of contra distinction to the
geo-engineering a lot of the proposals
that are happening with regards to the
restoration of ecosystems to use biology
to really deal with a lot of the things
the technology isn't dealing with some
of the things that for instance Paul
Hawkens been putting together in his new
book trawl down and I was wondering if
you had a chance to kind of review any
of the proposals around how we kind of
have we've been thinking about climate
change in an inverted kind of way where
we blame co2 but it's actually the
disruption of the ecosystems and the
capacity to stabilize a lot of the
cycles of water and carbon that are
really the issues yeah well I think that
they both are one thing it's not just
destructions of the ecological systems
are a disaster and are part of the
catastrophe that we're in the long
emergency that we're in but also burning
a fossil carbon we're not necessarily
gonna happen unless we did it so these
are two different problems and stopping
burning fossil carbon would be one thing
to do restoring ecological systems will
be another and drawing carbon down you
go forests you go peat beds you burn
charcoal and Beria there are ways of
join carbon down and a lot of talk now
of if you could pull co2 to the
atmosphere with your if every windmill
creating electricity was using a tenth
of that electricity to suck co2 out of
the atmosphere through chemical means
you might have then a whole much more
dry ice than we need you'd have to burry
that that's bad news but you could use
the carbon in carbon dioxide to make
graphene and then you could use graphene
to replace cement and cement is a huge
creator of carbon burn so that there are
some circular loops to carbon draw down
and really the tech is not the problem
this is why last year's talk was about
economics rather than tech because we've
got clean text we just can't afford to
pay ourselves to put them in place fast
enough because we're trying to make a
profit on everything and so this the
economic system that we're in if you
take the iPad formula our impact equals
population times appetite times
technology the real dangerous one and I
said this to Paul air like that it's not
appetite although you could call it that
it's the economic system that you're in
it's really the the capitalist system of
profit and shareholder value as the only
two values that are killing us yeah you
mentioned drawdown for those of you
don't know excellent book just came out
called drawdown by Paul Tom Styer or a
number of other people and it makes it
one fundamental point and you know
having been in Paris all we talked about
was taking co2 from a growth rate like
this to a growth rate like that as
opposed to what we actually have to do
which is to go like that that is
actually lower to the levels of co2
reduce the co2 right now all we're
talking about is slowing the rate of
growth of co2 yeah yeah I am I mean
Paris got us halfway to what we need
which was an immense historical
achievement but then we need more than
that that's why I like the name of
350.org yeah because that's aspirational
and it's a science fiction story and
we're heading 2500 at the moment it's a
kind of geoengineering story by the in
the name of that organization we have
time for one or two more questions one
back here got a lot farther into the
future okay it's all happens all these
bad things happen but then they figure
out a solution that in the future like
five hundred years from now and they
said okay we're going to put green land
back the way it's supposed to be and the
50 million people in Greenland say what
what do you mean supposed to be what's
what you have now is normal for the
average person what will happen in the
hundred years from that will also be
normal for the average person right yes
I mean well say all these horrible
changes are happening but then horrible
changes happen all the time
well people starve people you'll have
Wars yes
I take your point and I that's one of
the things I'm doing in New York 21 40
young people in the super Venice that is
drowned lower Manhattan are gonna be
trying to have fun and trying to get by
and Greenland the ice on Greenland is a
is a artifact of the Ice Age it just is
10,000 years slow to melt relative to
everywhere else and if it were to melt
it would be a really interesting place
and we are gonna be on a manga planet
from now on and we are going to be
adapting to the weirdnesses that we
ourselves have created that's what it
means to be in the Anthropocene which is
a real thing and worth discussing
however we're facing a mass extinction
event that could cause I mean the fact
we got 8 billion people on this planet
is it is an artificial creation of
civilization itself and carrying
capacity this planet is unknown but what
we don't want is a mass extinction event
that we lose all our fellow mammals and
we lose well I don't know a billion or
two people that would be bad okay that
would be like World War two and World
War one and when you can see it coming
in advance and you actually know the
story of of 1900 to 1914 when you see a
disaster bearing down on you what you
would want to say to future generations
as well we saw it coming and we dodged
it so we've got to avoid extinctions and
we got to avoid mass deaths and other
than that it's a Marvel planet and and
we're always going to be dealing with
mixed new Ecology's that we've made
ourselves so that's fine as long as we
share it with the rest of the animals
and actually making these mongrel
bastardized Ecology's that we're going
to have to make is going to be what
saves us in the end from the the mass
death scenario so I want to make a
distinction between you know oh because
this is a Deep Ecology view you know
what if only three or four billion
people who dive we'd be better off the
earth would be better off that's not a
good message
and I'm just didn't say before we get
our next question I just want to remind
everybody Stan is going to be sticking
around so if you're here you don't have
a chance to ask your question Stan
sticking around he's going to sign books
he's going to talk to the rest of us and
make this LAN part of this series really
happen so please stick around and also
just a shout out to Borderlands folks
who have a lot more of Stan's books here
so make sure you have everyone out there
wherever you're listening and sapote
support your in the local sci-fi
bookstore everybody so here's our next
question
so hopefully this question is not too
much along non-sequitur but you've just
sort of walked into it um so we've been
talking a lot about technologies and
things but I wonder in writing a books
and thinking about this what do you
think are the human qualities or society
qualities that either are most important
or under that wouldn't need to be
encouraged or that you would pick three
if you had to kind of what do you think
of the important human qualities or
societal qualities that we could focus
on developing as we go into this age oh
my lord
as a novelist I would just say you know
it's each person is completely different
and so this is hard so I would I did
want to shift that into a political mode
and just say anything to the left
anything progressive first
anti-austerity then Keynesianism then
social democracy then post capitalism as
if so you you've got to fight the
present battle which is you can call it
anti austerity you can call it anti
Trump anything well the the central wing
in America it means of reforming the
Democratic Party and shifting it to the
left in an effective way that appeals to
everybody and wins the electoral college
elections so there's that first step and
then you get into an agreement that
Keynesianism is really a description of
reality as such and and you support both
government and business in a
teeter-totter where they both
healthy and then you go to social
democracy like in Scandinavia where
you've got a social safety net and
you've got full employment and you've
got free education that these are the
pushes that are pretty damned obvious
and so if you can tell that story and
make them sound as obvious as they seem
to me and to and this is a kind of a San
Francisco thing you know there are two
California ideologies a lot of people in
Europe when they say the California
Diala gee I'm going yeah that's that's
me and what they mean is the libertarian
Silicon Valley silver bullet we can cure
this with better coding blah blah blah
and that's what they mean by the
California ideology whereas I want to
point to San Francisco's social life its
progressivism and the kind of left-wing
politics that is dragging America you
know to the left to the extent that it
is so there's even a battle over what
does it mean by the work you know what
is what is the term California ideology
mean but as a you know patriotic
California and I just love what's
happened here in the last I don't know
100 years or so because it started as an
accident and as a gold rush and as throw
pointed out these are desperate people
misguided deluded and desperate people
who came out here in search of gold and
so you know we still have that tradition
in Silicon Valley and we said that
tradition in Hollywood between the gold
rush Hollywood Silicon Valley and the
Sierra Nevada and the coastline and this
Bay we've got a we've got a problem it's
the place is too beautiful it's too
charismatic it's too populated and it's
the the pressures are enormous and yet
we still have made this unstable but
good place multicultural 100 languages
spoken a mixed cultures races
ethnicities etc that have all come here
and so there's only a few Native
Americans left and they're doing okay
some of them because of the casino
system the whole system here has
conspired by accident by an accident of
history to make something quite bizarre
and and it's like you're we're on a
tightrope of some sort and we could be
leading the way in
these ways so we got to think not the
California D ology that is the technical
fix and the computer fix and
libertarianism you've got to think the
California ideology that is progressive
movement the New Deal the the
multicultural and all-inclusive
diversity of San Francisco so it's kind
of weird because Silicon Valley in San
Francisco a there are two parts of an
integrated wheeler like to Hindu gods
fighting each other and there are only
about a hundred miles apart or eighty
miles apart
and yet they represent divergent views
of how to go forward and maybe you can
collapse them together I mean that's
kind of what some of the people here are
all about but it's well we're in a good
spot to make an interesting impact on
the whole situation stay with that let's
go impact stand up
Wow so something we do at law now is we
have these challenge medals which we
learn from the national security
community you are part of our security
hello daughter
it says carpe millennium he truly seizes
the millennium we give these for people
with big vision big heart and big impact
well thank you
[Applause]
[Music]